is the iphone 14 pro max really worth
200 more than the iphone 14 plus or
should you just save that money or
invest it into upgrading your storage
well there are some significant
differences between these phones and i
think that some of you guys are going to
regret the decision that you quickly
made so in this video i will cover not
only all the differences but also the
similarities and in what ways the 14
plus is actually better than the pro max
and ultimately helping you make the
right choice i'm going to start out with
some simple differences and then get
into the heavy hitters now you guys
obviously know that we have color
differences and you know your preference
so i'm going to skip to what really
stands out now the size of the displays
are the same that's a major selling
point but what isn't is the materials we
have aluminum on the plus and stainless
steel on the pro max now stainless steel
does look nice but there's major
downsides first off fingerprints you can
see them you have to wipe it all the
time compared to aluminum where you
don't have that and i think that you
notice scratches way more on the
stainless steel as well i definitely
notice it on mine but with that said
if you do drop it the stainless steel is
much more sturdy and protective with
that the back glass which is very
expensive to replace does have some
differences the plus has this shiny
finish that is glossy it shows a lot of
fingerprints
but it gives you a nice grip to it
whereas the pro max i love the matte
finish it feels great doesn't leave
fingerprints
but it is a little bit more slippery now
since we're talking about durability
scratches and cracks let me tell you
about the sponsor of this video taurus
they make simple unique and very
affordable cases for iphones including
the new iphone 14s the first one we have
is the guardian and one unique feature
is that you can actually swap out these
nice hard buttons on the side with these
other ones that have different colors if
you want a little bit of a pop this one
has military grade protection and it has
this bump which they call an airbag it's
patented and absorbs all the shock to
protect your cameras the next one is the
u-pro which has this translucent back on
there that also protects it it has this
kickstand built right in so if you're
going to be watching movies you pop it
right open and it will hold your phone
for you and there is still room for
charging next is the diamond clear which
is slim and lightweight it has ultra
high transparency and industry leading
anti-yellowing they also have the upro
and clear and the guardian with maxsafe
so go ahead and check them out using the
links down below and get yourself a case
that is affordable and that will protect
your phone now apple talked about crash
detection and spent a ton of time on
satellite connectivity and thankfully
both of the phones have this both of
them have the same exact waterproofing
and a lot of the other upgrades apply as
well such as bluetooth 5.3 which they
could have saved for the pros but they
didn't now the one thing that really
stands out is the difference in
processors and i have to say that's
probably not going to be the deal
breaker where people were getting upset
that the new iphones have an old chip
now if you're comparing to the pro max
the latest benchmarks do show that
there's a 17 difference in cpu and an
eight percent difference in graphics but
of course even the a15 and the a14 were
so fast that it doesn't make a major
difference now one area where i think
there is going to be a difference is
battery life with the plus being better
now apple mentioned that has the best
battery life in any iphone ever but that
was raiding audio playback whereas in
video playback it is actually worse than
the 14 pro max and that's just because
of the extra efficiency of the a16 chip
but personally i think that if you are a
lighter user you will get better battery
life out of the 14 plus
just because it has a larger battery in
general and it doesn't have some of
these extra features that eat up extra
battery that doesn't show up on those
spec sheets for example we have to talk
about the display because this is where
we have a ton of differences what really
shocked everybody was the dynamic island
which is the new version of the notch
and not only does it look different but
they're using it as a part of the ui so
a lot of shortcuts and apps and controls
and notifications are going to be shown
there and this does look super cool it
is handy but personally it's not like
this is something that you have to have
it makes a massive difference in actual
usability it is more of a luxury feature
now where i do think it will matter is
upcoming years and i'll talk about that
at the end now one thing that really
really matters to me is the always-on
display now apple's able to do this
because the screen goes down to one
hertz now which saves battery on the 14
pro max and of course if you enable
always on display it's going to use
extra
but it is so nice to have all your
notifications showing up there just dims
down and if your phone is laying there
you see all that instead of having to
tap it now promotion also taps into that
because that variable refresh rate goes
up to 120 hertz which makes the phone so
so smooth if you've never experienced
this on the iphone 13s man it is amazing
to have but there is a major downside if
all of your other devices that you use
only have 60 hertz for example maybe
your ipad
you know your different computer
monitors all of that when you're used to
your iphone everything else just seems
slow and glitchy so at that point you
want to upgrade your other devices or it
gets annoying but personally if you can
afford it it is nice to have now where
things get really different are the
cameras and i know not everybody cares
about cameras but i still want to touch
on it where it really matters apple
showed off the 48 megapixel camera and
it looks really good but the 14 plus
gets the camera from the iphone 13 pro
max so it's still a very very good
camera but there are some limitations
first off you're not going to get the
prores raw you're not going to get
progress video does not matter i'm
somebody so many photos and i will say
no it does not matter i've used both of
those but they take up way more space
the results aren't that much better so
even if you get the pro max i don't
think a lot of you guys will use that
now with that the action mode still
works great on both as well as the
cinematic mode it works in 4k hdr in
both which is great but the larger
sensor of the 14 pro max will make it
more accurate along with that the
front-facing cameras are identical they
are both new and much improved so if you
love selfies there's no different but
the other difference really comes in
with that three times telephoto lens and
with lidar having that three times
telephoto allows you to zoom in 15 times
instead of five and it looks so much
better on the iphone 13 series so the
same thing's gonna go with this setup if
you like to zoom in you have kids or
animals further away it makes a dramatic
difference it also allows you to take
portraits with that lens which does give
you a whole different perspective more
like a realistic camera
and with that the lidar sensor if you
take portrait shots at night it allows
for night mode the 14 plus still doesn't
have that and there is a shocking
difference
in terms of the quality the brightness
the sharpness all of that so overall if
you care about cameras it is such a huge
difference you have so much more options
with the 14 pro max now this is where we
have to talk about resale value some
people don't care about that but other
people do
now if you're going to be selling your
14 plus say in a year from now to
upgrade to the 15 well the 15s are going
to get that dynamic island as well at
that point the 14s are going to get
outdated much quicker than previous
iphones where we didn't have that
difference so i would definitely think
about that and if you're somebody that
doesn't resell their phone you keep it
for a long time say three four even five
years you have to think well this is
actually 200 bucks but what difference
is that price when you spread it over
five years and if you're going to be
sticking for phone that long that's
where i would highly recommend to get
the 14 pro max not only do you get that
new design that's going to stay fresh
for a long time with a new notch always
on display much better cameras you have
the lidar you just get so much more
value for that 200 price now who should
buy the 14 plus i would say two people
one somebody that doesn't have great
eyesight or you really like a big screen
but you know don't care about anything
else you'd be happy with an iphone 6
iphone 7 and two if you need the best
battery life because if you're not a
heavy user and your screen is going to
be off for a long time and you're not
gonna be pushing your phone hard with
games and other things the standby time
should be really good with this phone
much better than what apple specs show
off so there you guys go please do not
make the wrong choice look over all of
the differences that i talked about and
think about how long you're going to
have this phone and what that price
difference really breaks down to
over the long term a lot of people
should be getting the pro max instead of
the plus and it looks like based on
pre-orders a lot of people are
pre-ordering that instead so there you
guys go go ahead and check out taurus
all those cases with links down below
they're incredibly priced the quality is
good
and click above to subscribe to see more
videos like this one check out one of
those videos right over there this has
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]